okay let's take one more call here 617
830 4750 do we have a caller from
overseas here yes hello my name is John
were you calling from John can you hear
me I'm coming from England your NATO
ally united kingdom what's on your mind
John I wanna know what the hell's going
on we're we're really worried over here
yeah I you know I wish I had some
explanation for you uh what give me a
sense like what are people most scared
about over there with Trump um well I
think we've we loved the Obama okay I
mean that was a great president you
don't need me to tell you that and I
think obviously England's or the United
Kingdom's been relevant because of the
brexit comparison right um my question
is there's a kind of a really sort of
subtle Democrat demographic irunium
breaks it in the most young people voted
to remain and if this vote would have
five or 10 years from now generationally
we would never have voted to leave the
European Union in my opinion because the
older people wouldn't be around sure uh
so is that a do you think
demographically there's a kind of a
longer term look into the future
whatever happens over the next four
years happens but is it true to suggest
that longer-term given the youth vote in
America the same is true of a potential
sort of Trump backlash because at least
you can buy him out well i mean i think
there's there's two sides to this number
one is that yes generally speaking
younger people tend to be more
progressive and less likely to vote
republican and that the sort of aging
out of right wing voters will continue
to move the country to the left the
counter to that is because of the timing
of the trump presidency in the reality
that he'll likely select yeah three or
four Supreme Court justices may be only
two if there's some people that stay on
the court longer than maybe is
anticipated uh he is going to in those
four years irreversibly move
the next several decades potentially to
the right so I think that you're there's
an analogy you're drawing which is
accurate but the impact of selecting
Supreme Court justices is just so major
that in spite of the country but the
individuals continuing to move to the
left over the next 10 or 20 years three
supreme court justice is that a
right-wing could keep the country pretty
right and corporatist for a long time if
you know what I mean John yeah I execu I
mean that's a really good point yeah all
right we'll listen thank you so much for
the call we do have to run a lot to get
to today but always great to hear from
our friends in the United Kingdom we
heard from John in Britain today thank
you so much for the call I really really
appreciate it that is going to do it for
calls this week we have a lot of other
great stuff to talk about I'm glad
you're joining me and remember you can
use coupon code I voted 17 to get a
forty percent discount off of membership
at david pakman.com slash membership
will take a break and be back with
plenty more of the friday show after
this